and i know toby's been a menace
but for all his fumbling
leading up to castle moore
bro kind of carried
how so
i think bro carried the season did he
until that point
yeah
season was kind of mid yeah but tobe i
think he carried yeah big dub for tub
honest uh
honest yeah honest
i'm being honest i'm being honest
honest
no he did it everything was lame
everyone was in love
i don't i don't know if they're putting
guns to their heads to be like find love
yeah but he was the only one just doing
what you want to see on a reality tv
show which is like man just [ __ ] it up
yeah yeah you know just go crazy it was
everyone was kind of being a little bit
too decisive it's like this is my person
and i'm happy now and it's like that's
not
really well i mean it's why people watch
love island because
i don't know like
the winners are always the people that
like the uk votes as like the best
couple or whatever it's like sort of why
people watch it but it's also you want
that drama yeah you only want to be that
way yeah deserving yeah
dude him just
like you just want to like just shake
them and be like just [ __ ] decide
like make one decision like the whole
time he's sitting there he's like it's
so hard i don't know because they both
like me and i don't know just [ __ ]
decide just make a decision make one
decision
i love watching him learn about other
people's feelings in real time yeah
if it kills me like i think
when i do these things it's not his
voice at all
it hurts other people yeah and that just
kills me it's like oh wow
this is dude we've had like a personal
breakthrough [ __ ] hugo being like and
that's what you call empathy yeah when
they got into hugo's call out to him was
crazy yes yes i raised wanted so bad to
discuss that last week that was
actually pretty hard
like
i got it i got to say like it was i
think it was like it was like a little
bit simp
yeah that's what i'm saying it was like
it was white knighting for sure it was
it was it was kind of nice guying a
little bit yeah
it was she deserves that
uh you're on a reality tv show man get
out of here and then the worst part was
is that he tries to like hook up with
her after
like directly after you can see
they go to kiss or something like that
and he kind of like
maybe tries to plant like a sneaky one
on the lips and she's like no and then
she like does the friend hug and then
afterwards when he goes up to her and
basically like pitches like what about
us you know anything could happen what
do you think and she's like no yeah
she's my brother she unhinged her jaw
twice as much as she does for toby and
she was like
no
no
no
no
i can't see it
no
he's like right yeah right
yeah but like
but like i'm a little mousy
[Laughter]
don't you wanna
you know
no
yeah
i can't see it
yeah he got owned it was kind of yeah
i thought the moment was really cool
because i think toby did [ __ ] her over
like big time yeah like a guy was an
[ __ ] yeah he was an idiot yeah and so
told us to to couple up with
uh what's her face chloe
no no no no no no abby yeah yeah couple
up with abby like that
and leave her sitting there
at risk of being dumped too yeah
that was actually the best part of that
whole thing was who was standing there
georgia
um the blonde one that hugo that tried
to get with hugo
yes she was standing there and all the
drama like she was saying they're about
to get dumped
and all the drama was circulating around
chloe and toby and hugo and she's just
standing there like i'm the one about to
leave yeah is this not sad too yeah do
you guys not give a [ __ ] at all about me
that whole speech
you've been here
yeah
and she got it they're like oh and
abby's just dumped and everyone like
just kind of looked back to like uh all
right bye have a nice day right bye
[Laughter]
thank you so much thank you yeah toby
definitely was caring in that way yeah
yeah it kind of put the show on his back
a little bit you could
and you know in one in cell respect you
could say toby
his intentions weren't pure
you could you could or you could
question his intentions you do that nice
kind of move so you could pitch and you
got [ __ ] owned
you know yeah
yeah that's true toby i mean on toby
hugo was getting a little
spray yeah hugo was getting a little and
then
it all came to a close when he finally
got his first romantic connection in
castlemore
with what's her face what's her name i
don't even know
amy sure whatever we could say anything
i'd be like yeah yeah yeah right
beatrice
so they kiss amy and hugo
and he's like what does he say it's a
job done job done
i was like dude what are you doing
such a teacher thing to do
job done i'm finally on love island i'm
like just act like you've been there for
two seconds it's trying to dry her up
what are you doing you like basically
trying to dry her up
i mean like she's like very clearly into
him right they have this passionate kiss
and he's like all right check that off
the list i finally got a case bro he
basically like
kissed her and then
took his audio headset and like spiked
it on the ground and then like called
all the dudes over yeah you know what i
mean it just started like hugging and be
like we going kiss we go kiss we got a
kiss and she's just sitting there like
what's happened
[Music]
glad for the day i finally got my kids
so my love island journey has finally
begun it's finally over yes that's why
i'll be leaving the show
[Music]
yeah bro he's i don't know i don't know
what the [ __ ] is up with that dude
i don't like him i don't like him
i don't like him he's a nice guy but
that's it
yeah he makes me cringe yeah a little
bit
no no no
that part was just brutal i don't want
to be nice to him i mean like he does do
things that yeah are just like oh like
they they are they are cringed dude
you're cringe bro dude you're so cringe
huge
but yeah like i don't know just that
moment was like yeah we did it yeah job
done it's like don't say that like don't
like act like you like her too like not
just she's like some conquest so you
just yeah i know finished
and now you're like she's sitting right
beside you like you probably kiss her
again if you wanted to but instead he's
just like all right
completed thank you so much by the way
thank you that's why you could you know
you could say is it just for the tv yeah
it was easy even there to like i don't
know find someone i just pictured it i
just pictured him like smashing her in
the hideaway
then immediately after like nutting he
just like gets that slips out of the bed
and then finds the closest mirror and
like high-fives himself yeah it's just
like
yeah right you've done it you've done it
you go you lost your virginity
i can't believe it mate it's like it's
been a long time coming and you finally
lost it
um
on tv what was that
oh i was a virgin
yeah
yeah we was virgins i was i was
hell
what if people from newcastle just use
us because they're all like
two percent clinically insane oh
i see if you're born in newcastle the
water like
you know from day one when you look in
the mirror you think it's two of you
yeah you know yeah
that's a sick theory
i'm sure they'll really appreciate that
yeah i'm sure they will i'm sure all of
newcastle complains about that yeah i'm
sure new all of newcastle will confirm
this they'll be like
yeah i always all crazy and i'll be like
wait you or all of you well us
that makes me laugh so hard